foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by my good friend Christina Ellis
and we are taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money maybe you need a second
opinion and need some motivation some
inspiration uh you're at a Crossroads we
are here for you we want to help you
take the right next step with your money
Larry kicks us off this hour in Houston
Texas Larry welcome to the Ramsay show
how you doing
doing well and how how y'all doing doing
great how can we help
well thanks for taking my call to start
it off but um
just wanted to I wanted to ask the
question uh my wife and I are trying to
get tired of being in debt
and uh trying to get back on track and
and uh got us I've got a daughter that's
a sophomore in in high school right now
and uh her goal is to go to college and
I haven't done any saving
um
uh
we had our own business for 15 years and
and 2020 we was we we was uh we had to
shut it down and so the thing what
happened was is uh
all the
savings and we had and all that stuff I
tried to I put back into the company to
try to keep it going and so anyhow my
main thing is is I just needed some some
encouragement or
some guidance I'm sorry to hear about
your business Larry that's a tough thing
and so many business owners felt that
same pain during the pandemic how are
you guys doing now financially
and we're I I believe that I believe
that I make good money uh my wife got a
part-time job now uh the thing is it
just seems like we don't
we don't know where where it went you
know how much like what's your household
income
household is 130 and how much that a
year
uh 35
000. what kind of debt is that
uh my wife's Jeeps we owe 15 000 on her
Jeep and um
uh and some credit cards we owe nine
thousand dollars on some credit cards
and we have a a camper that we owe about
nine thousand dollars on okay and what's
the conversation been like with your
daughter regarding college
she she wants to go to college she wants
to be a vet and uh that weighs heavy on
my heart because I don't want to have to
tell her that I don't want to I don't
want to have to go with debt that's a
thing well Larry I think you represent a
lot of parents right now I think a lot
of parents are in your situation they
have kids in high school and they're
like oh my gosh they see the cost of
tuition and they're just overwhelmed by
it so I think first thing is just take a
deep breath and there are so many
different strategies just because you
don't have the money to pay for it out
of pocket right now does not mean that
she can't go to that school so what have
the conversations looked about money
with her so if you had this conversation
about finances and the cost of college
well yes ma'am and and the thing is is
um they're big into Ag and things like
that so they do show animals and when
they make selling their animals well
more fortunate to make sale but we do
put money back for them for their for
their college things like that but I'd
like to try to find out about some some
uh I listen to y'all quite a bit and
some scholarships you know there's one
personality with y'all that went to
college on nothing but you're talking to
her buddy there you go there she is how
perfect I was telling yeah I was telling
her the other day I was like there was a
lady that you know got a half a million
dollars in scholarships but where do we
start how do we do that to where she can
uh and and with our school also one
great thing is with our school
um
uh her high school that she can come out
with a two-year College uh so a long
Star College is actually with our school
also and she is in college classes plus
High School classes but um
she sounds really bright so so from what
I can gather she's motivated to pursue
this herself she's motivated to figure
out how to pay for it is that a correct
assessment
yes and no I mean she she wants to do
her she she's kind of like I am I guess
if she's not for sure I I really don't
know the thing is is uh she's she wants
to go to college her and her cousin have
this big uh goal that they're both going
to be vets and have their own practice
and and I don't want to beat that down I
mean she's really good and she's good
with animals and that's she's been
wanting to do that for a long time well
the very first thing I'm going to say
you should do is sit down and watched
borrowed future or documentary to do
that together make it a movie night and
that can really start some conversations
because one of the biggest things in
talking to a high school student a lot
of times they just don't realize what
they're up against they've never had to
pay for a mortgage they don't know how
it is to pay monthly bills so having
those conversations early about you know
this is what student loan debt is when
you turn 18 when you go to college
there's going to be all these people who
are offering you student loans but
there's another way and that documentary
it really lays it out because I found a
lot of parents you know it's hot it's
hard to have that conversation a lot of
times students are resistant to it
they're like I don't want to hear it all
my friends are taking out student loans
and I just want to take out a student
loan and YOLO and figure it out later
but this documentary it lays out the
consequences a student loans we talked
to doctors and we talked to people who
took out debt and now you know they're
10 years from their degree and they're
in tears because they're still
overwhelmed so having that picture
painted as to the why why to avoid debt
I think that's the very first step and
that can hopefully trigger some
motivations to start pursuing
scholarships to start doing the research
and I love that you're so motivated as a
parent because part of my story was my
mom got in the ring with me she didn't
have the money to pay for college she
was like that's disappointing that's
frustrating but what I can do is I can
get in the ring with you and help you
figure out scholarships we're going to
go to the library together we're going
to set aside time and carve out small
goals for making this happen so you know
be willing to do the research you know
help her walk through you know if you
apply to so many scholarships a week
this is how much it's going to be over
six months help her create that vision
for why this is motivating and then get
tactical a lot of times parents you know
you can sit down with your students and
think through you know what are the best
scholarships for my student to apply for
that's usually one of the things that
like is just overwhelming for students
actually finding the scholarships there
are millions of scholarships out there
given away every year billions of
dollars but you have to narrow them down
and figure out which ones fit you best
so really sitting down and helping
create that list so that you can start
applying for scholarships that's going
to be key and there's a really great
database called scholarship owl that we
work with and we just love them they do
a great job of kind of filtering out
some of the scam scholarships some of
the junk scholarships to get you a
really targeted list
okay yeah and that's one thing is she
don't want she hasn't talked about
getting any you know
um uh loans or anything like that I
think she wants to I'm pretty sure she
wants to go debt free they both the kids
are way better than uh than I was with
money whenever I was that age you know
that means you raised them right Larry
yeah
yeah exactly so one more question on
that too is my wife and I want to get
out of debt we're we're starting it now
um three months ago I sold my 17 Tundra
um I had to you know I was 4 000 upside
down I went to my bank uh they gave me
the loan for four grand after I paid
after I sold it uh the thing is is
um I might not communicate all the time
so my I've got my wife on board with the
uh
uh getting out of debt okay but but she
she how do I get her to where we're
she's wanting to do like uh the same
page that I'm on oh I got the perfect
thing for you Larry hang on the line
we're going to send you Financial Peace
University go through all nine lessons
with her get on a budget using every
dollar that's a part of it and get rid
of this debt and soon you'll be able to
actually help your daughter cash flow
College you can do this man your 35k in
debt you make 130 sell the camper do
whatever you have to do to set yourself
free financially and you'll be on the
path thanks for the call
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by
Christina Ellis triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money well here we are in
2023 most of you are glad to be done
with 2022 because it was a tough year it
was hard enough just to keep gas in the
car food in the fridge and money is
still tight and you might be wondering
is this year going to be any different
are we going to make any progress are we
going to be just as stressed as we were
last year well good news for you you
don't have to live through another year
of stress and worry regardless of what
happens in the economy so watch our free
live stream Building Wealth in 2023
happening this Thursday night because we
want to show you that it's still
possible to make progress on your goals
build wealth and have peace with money
even in this crazy economy
during the event you're going to hear
from Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz myself Dr
John deloney and Ken Coleman we're going
to show you how to set goals how to
create margins so that you have the
ability to build wealth this year
whatever your goals may be we're gonna
have some fun as well there's some fun
surprises that I can't leak out just yet
we'll get there and uh here's the good
news even if the economy feels out of
control you don't have to be so please
register for the free live stream at
ramseysolutions.com wealth tell your
friends again it's completely free you
can tune in from wherever you are around
the world and ramseysolutions.com wealth
is the place to sign up we'll get you
all the information you need
all right let's go to the phones JoJo
joins us up next in New York City JoJo
welcome to the show
hi thank you how you doing
uh better than I deserve as they would
say I love it how can we help today
um so three weeks ago today basically to
the hour
um I came home from work to find that my
Cottage burnt down oh my goodness yeah I
lost everything including the cat
um the cat yeah Abigail oh yeah it's
it's it's been a ride
um it's been an absolute ride
um and I rented and I had no renters
insurance
um but I have a community to get to the
point of uh of love that is just
ridiculous um and God is using this for
good he's putting me on the track that I
needed to be on and I'm just so grateful
for it on every level
um but GoFundMe was set up
um there's about 97 000 right now I'm
about I'm George Bailey right now wow
talk about a community wow oh my
goodness
full of love and then this Thursday
sadly I'm gonna miss that live stream I
wanted to watch it but they're having to
go nautical for me they're having a
fundraiser music is a big music
community and they put together five of
my favorite bands and there's going to
be more money coming in from that maybe
a few more thousand I'm gonna it's
incredible and easily yeah wow well
there's some silver lining there for
sure oh no doubt so how can we help
today um so that being said um I started
the Dave Ramsey course again uh failed
at it years ago but now it's like taking
control and it feels great let's go good
money I make good money I don't have
much debt I got some back taxes that I
need to talk to the accountant about I
got a truck that's 2016 Tundra about 16
000 I owe on it
where do I go with this money do I pay
the truck off
um eventually I want to buy a house I
still need to live but I don't want to
take anything from this to live I want
to find you know hopefully God just put
something in place that I can afford
because what I had was an incredible
deal the rent I had was amazing it's
unheard of here in the Hamptons
um and I need to uh find something like
that again I just want to I'll rebuild
day by day with the Ramsay thing and
with my normal work so I got all this
money that has to alligate to a future
for myself
um well welcome back welcome back on
board we're proud of you that's that's
wonderful so is that 16 000 is that all
of your debt is the car everything
besides the back taxes which I'm not
sure there may be nine to 13 000 in back
taxes that have been holding off since
2013 I don't give them anything but they
are going to come after me
um and then there's another thousand
dollars in unsecured like PayPal credit
card uh which I make payments every
month on okay and with this money that
you're getting from the fundraisers and
from the GoFundMe
um how much with with the rental and
with the fire loss what was the total
loss on that
I'm sorry say that one more time so with
what you lost in the fire what is your
total loss like what is the amount
the the amount of like as far as
problems money property everything like
how much money are you trying to raise
what is the goal with that
um well I'm not
I don't know if I'm trying to raise
anything for the stuff I lost that's all
you know I had a final vintage
collection that was worth thousands and
concert posters that are worth thousands
of dollars and I'm not trying to replace
any of that stuff
um I mean I will but not with this money
that I got from them eventually I'll
just build up so where are you where are
you living right now
all right so a friend has a place that
he rents out in the summer so I got
three months of being here however my
rent if that's what you're asking it was
a thousand dollars a month and 500 worth
of Labor because I was a caretaker of
the property on top of my regular job
and it's unheard of so you won't find
that again I would love to before that I
was paying 1300 to rent a room where I
didn't feel comfortable in a person's
kitchen or living room you know what I
mean what's your income
my income is about uh annually with my
side gigs yeah 120 000 I bring in okay
great so the good news is well and I
have child support okay how much is that
600 a month
um
yeah so we can clean up this debt real
quick and you can you can keep the truck
I want you to set aside the money for
taxes and start paying that regularly
you might want to do quarterly estimated
with your accountant to avoid the IRS
coming after you with fees and penalties
I mean you cannot get them off your back
so something you want to pay attention
to obviously going forward
and I would want to sit down with a tax
Pro because like you said you know
they're going to come for you at some
point but you're not really sure you
know exactly how much you owe what the
situation is so I wouldn't want to sit
down with a professional and kind of
walk through that walk through if
there's any you know extra fees any
extra things that you're going to have
to pay because especially with the IRS
you want Total Clarity and with this
money coming in you want to wipe them
out of your life that is not somebody
you want to be in debt to do you already
have money in the bank
aside from the 97
uh yeah I have uh about 4 000 saved on
my own okay so we're talking we got a
hundred grand what would we do to start
fresh on the Ramsay plan
yes well looks like about 30 of that
let's say is going to go towards debt
now we've got 70 right
now we need a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
so let's call that for round numbers
twenty thousand okay that now leaves you
with fifty thousand
and it puts us at baby step four where
we begin investing 15 of our income into
retirement so then we can start to walk
that out and go all right what are my
retirement options do you have a 401k
through an employer I do uh there's
about 50 000 in there right now okay is
there a Roth option with that or is it
traditional
I believe it's traditional now I did
borrow from it uh uh oh and I borrowed
again I borrowed against myself though
so I borrowed an oh see so I'm not sure
how that works but I owe 22 000 I pay
108 a month I'm not a month 108 a week
into that
um and it's a five percent interest that
comes back to me that's how it's written
so how dumb does JoJo have to be to
borrow money from himself with interest
that doesn't sound like a gift
you know it just uh it keeps the money
out of there making money for it yeah
JoJo guy sounds like a real jerk
charging you interested
so this is not a gift I'm paying off the
401K loan as part of the debt snowball
and so how much is the 401K alone total
looks like it's almost done
you're almost there is that oh wait say
that again how much is the 401K loan
what's left on it to pay back oh 22 000.
oh
okay well this money all of a sudden has
some jobs to do doesn't it you're not
going to have a whole lot left over to
have fun with but you know what you will
have your income back in your life
because you're not making all these
payments left and right on top of the
child support
right right now you're you've been out
earning the stupidity in a sense because
you're making good money but there's not
much left at the end of the month is
there
no and so I want to free up all of that
income so that you can use it to build
wealth to do the things that you want to
do to afford rent in the Hamptons which
is going to be absurdly expensive unless
you can find a situation like you had
before and so I'm listing out all the
debts everything from smallest to
largest and paying it off with that gift
money you have the rest is going to go
towards three to six months of expenses
begin investing 15 whatever's left over
you can park in a high yield savings
account and use that as a future down
payment to be a homeowner one day that
would be my goal for you JoJo so so
sorry for what you went through that's
tough and JoJo again just to re
reiterate the tax probe that money
coming in from fundraising make sure to
talk to a tax professional because there
may be gift tax that applies to that and
you don't want to once again be in
trouble with the IRS look into a do your
due diligence with the GoFundMe stuff
man wishing you the best after that
awful awful situation this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to nest suite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's get to our question of the
day comes from Corey in Oregon what does
Corey have to say Christina you often
say the best thing you can do is invest
in yourself so how is taking out a
student loan that will allow me to
drastically increase my income pay off
debt and build wealth faster such a bad
idea if I'm going to get such a good
return on my investment whoa
I like the snark in Cory but Cory's
gotta get off his assumptions there was
a lot going on here so number one he's
saying you often say the best thing you
can do is invest in yourself generally
when we say that we are talking about
people who are 18 19 20 saying hey I've
got I've got all this money what do I do
with it should I invest it into the
stock market and we don't know what
their future in education is do they
need that money to pay for that and so
that's why we say hey the best thing you
can do is invest in yourself instead of
the stock market right now there's that
but this idea of
the student loan is an investment it's
going to dramatically increase my income
and help me do all these things why is
it such a bad idea the ROI is there
Christina isn't it oh obviously it
always works out how we plan and the
thing is is that it doesn't always work
out there actually studies that show
that most students don't graduate in
four years a lot of students take either
six years or they don't graduate at all
actually 40 percent of students take six
years or don't graduate at all which is
a scary statistic we talk to people all
the time who have student loans that
didn't even get the degree
that's scary that's the scariest part is
if you don't finish you still owe that
money right and if you put strategy into
it you can go to college debt free so
the idea that you need to take on loans
to go to school that's just not true and
we also see people all the time who are
drowning in student loan debt so while
yes a lot of people take out student
loans a lot of people feel the pain and
ramifications from it and it's just not
worth it we say take loans completely
off the table yes invest in yourself
absolutely you need an education
um to some extent and that may look like
an apprenticeship that may look like an
internship they that may just look like
job experience but we want you to get
educated but just do it without debt yes
invest in yourself and we do it debt
free we cover a lot of this in the
borrowed future documentary but it comes
down to this philosophical issue of is
the college degree still worth what it
was and we're seeing over time it's just
worth less for our parents generation it
was a safe bet to get the degree because
you knew you were going to get a better
job because of it and that's just not
true today I mean I grew up in the
Northeast and half of my friends are
still working on their fourth master's
degrees and they've ever had a job and
I'm going what are you what are you guys
doing because the companies that are
going to hire are going to go do you
have the experience and yes they want
you to know how to do the job and part
of that is education but these days
there's so many ways to get it it's more
of a checking a box than it is hey
what's Christina what school did you go
to and unless you went to some Ivy
League school most companies don't give
a rip right well and it's not a knock on
education I still think the value of a
college degree is there but there are so
many other factors playing into it
before it seemed like it was a guarantee
you know you had to have a college
degree to be successful and we are
seeing all the time now that that's just
not true and it's time that the higher
education industry got checked because
for so long they just ran around like
you know they didn't have any
accountability they could just raise
tuition to whatever they wanted people
would just take out loans to pay for it
and I feel like we're finally getting
their attention and saying hey you can't
just charge whatever you want and put 18
year olds in thousands of dollars of
debt without us questioning well that's
par that's their entire marketing
strategy is if you go to our school wow
your kid's gonna have such a bright
future the ROI is always going to be
there and so it's part of the narrative
that your life is just going to be
better if you go to our school and what
we're finding is there's a lot of time
in between classes that turns out and
not everyone finishes and not all
degrees are equal and so if you got your
degree over here it may not be equal to
the one over here and so you've got to
think about what is my goal with this
education what job am I after what
career am I after does that career
actually require a four-year degree if
so great then do that and do it without
debt and do it the most affordable way
possible right and one of the things to
look at if we're going to talk about
return on investment look at College Roi
so there's starting to be a lot of
ratings and people evaluating colleges
based on their return on investment and
that is a really good thing we want to
make sure sure that that degree pays off
we're not just trying to get a degree
for a check mark just to say that we had
it we want it to have purpose we want it
to help us make more money and to be
more successful in our career so a few
things to look at when you're evaluating
Roi on a college you want to look at the
net price so a lot of times people will
look at a college and they just get
overwhelmed by the sticker price they're
like oh my gosh I could never afford
that school but there's this thing
called a net price calculator where you
can actually go on a school's website
you can type in your information you can
type in your GPA your test scores your
financial situation and they have to
tell you how much about an estimate of
what you will actually pay to go to that
school so they'll tell you potential
grants and scholarships and you can get
a better idea of what the college cost
will actually be another really
important thing to look at is the
four-year completion rate so if you're
thinking about going to a school that's
four years you know you're looking off
into the Horizon and you're thinking you
know this school costs twenty thousand
dollars okay I think I can afford that
but can you afford it if it takes you
five years can you afford it takes you
six years that's a whole different
equation that's twenty to forty thousand
dollars more which a lot of schools are
way more than that so this could be a
huge huge difference so you know look on
average do most students finish that
school in four years and a lot of times
that data is out there and the
statistics are scary they say there was
a study that was done that said only 40
of students finish school in four years
yikes that's crazy and then 20 take
between four and six years and forty
percent don't graduate at all and you
know sometimes this is because of a
student you know not having ambition
they're slacking off they're going to
parties but a lot of times it's because
the school's not great at scheduling
maybe some of the classes that are
requirements aren't actually available
they're difficult to get into or they
don't have great advisors that help
students walk through exactly what they
need to graduate in four years you know
so look at those look at those
statistics see if you're likely to
actually finish that degree in four
years and then another big thing that
you think would would be really obvious
is earning potential oh that that's such
a fun word earning potential right I'm
gonna make so much more money because I
went to this school and how do we figure
that piece out well look at the stats
you know look at the stats on you know
the different Majors within the school
how much are their graduates typically
earning that's important then also look
at your specific major I mean this is
kind of hard to choke down but we've
talked to a lot of teachers who went and
got 200 000 educations to make thirty
eight thousand dollars a year
that's tough I mean we love teachers and
by all means we need teachers we need
teachers to get educated but unless you
have a lot of scholarships unless you're
getting grants to go to a specific
school that's cost two hundred thousand
dollars a year you're probably not going
to get a great return on investment like
we've talked to teachers that over have
over a hundred thousand dollars in
student loans and it's you know two
three times their salary you got to
think about those things in advance you
don't want to put yourself in that
situation where even best case scenario
you're not likely to Roi yeah that's
scary and I hate that we have to keep
saying this but you've got to do the
math and most people are just following
their hearts deepest passions because
that's what we taught our kids was just
follow your dreams and go to college at
all costs and that's that's the path to
success in the American dream and they
get out of school and they've got a pile
of payments they can't afford rent they
can't breathe they can't even do the
jobs they wanted to do because they got
to get that paycheck and pay the bills
right and it's like it's important when
looking at a major even if it looks
really cool even if it's something fun
to to study even if you're interested in
it like you still need to have a career
path after that there still has to be
some way to make money from that I mean
you can read books you can do things for
pleasure you know go to a library and
read books for fun but when we're
talking about something you are paying
for that you are hoping to get a return
on like you need to be clear about the
numbers up front is this degree is this
major going to pay off well and we've
got to talk about the alternative
careers out there like the trades
they're so overlooked undervalued
they're poo pooed by the parents out
there and yet we get calls on the Ramsay
show and they're going oh yeah I've got
no debt and I make 85 000 a year as a
plumber and I'm going that guy is
winning oh Junior over here with his
fancy four-year six-year degree who's
making 40. uh let's do the math on that
one parents well and one more thing is
opportunity cost like if you want to go
into a trade you may not need a
four-year degree and if you didn't do
the four-year degree how much money
could you have been making in that time
that you were in school well this all
starts with the conversation with your
kids don't leave it up to chance don't
leave it to the guidance counselors this
is on you parents start the conversation
early and often even if you can't afford
it we've got to get a game plan for
these generations to graduate debt free
with actual jobs on the other side this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Ramsey
personality Christina Ellis and we are
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five hey I know we
get a lot of new listeners to the show
and if you are new to the show you want
to learn more about these baby steps
we're always talking about you want to
know how to get started on the Ramsay
way you can go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on the get started button if
you're on your desktop computer you'll
see that in the top right if you're on
mobile just hit the menu and you'll see
it right there at the bottom it'll say
get started our team has created this
tool to help you figure out the best
Next Step based on your specific
situation so you answer a few quick
questions I want to guide you to the
best resources the best tools to get you
started on the path
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started let's go to Andrew over in
Phoenix Arizona Andrew welcome to the
show
thank you it's great to be here I've
listened to your show for a few years
and
um it's cool to be the caller it's it's
like you're inside of the Matrix Man
welcome it's a good time we're happy to
have you how can we help today thank you
so my question first of all is just what
the next best financial step would be to
take I'm recently married we just got
married a few months ago and we're
currently
um
or our household income is around 70 000
um I'm planning on starting a master's
degree in August where we'll have to
move States for that
um and we're planning on cash flowing
that whole thing uh we don't want to
take an account in debt for that good
and so basically bring should we kind of
try and start maybe step four or uh
maybe start on what I've heard you call
a 3B um saving for a down payment for a
home
um or just focus on maybe renting for a
while
so you guys have no debt and you have
the fully funded emergency fund
currently
yeah we have about 50 000 in savings and
then ten thousand and I'm an index fund
currently great and will that cover the
Master's Degree without touching the
emergency fund or do you need to
continue saving for that
yeah it will and um that'll cost around
twenty five thousand um just for the
tuition and then we'll probably save up
around 40 000 more before we have to
move
so 25 000 total for the whole master's
degree
is that correct yeah what's the program
yeah
it's a public administration
cool and is that something that you just
want to seek out uh to to get a
different job or a different career
what's driving that yeah
I graduated
um in Biochemistry and I want to be more
in like healthcare administration
something more business related so and
that program just would allow me to gain
some of those skills and accounting and
other leadership skills and where do you
have to move
it's up to Salt Lake wow and your wife
is cool with this
yeah she is she's cool with it she's
actually here with me she she just
bought me a whole bunch of the books for
Christmas and stuff so what a lady
that's awesome and is that gonna affect
her job
yeah so she actually just uh works from
home right now just part-time so she can
kind of do it anywhere okay and what
about you the 70k will you continue
making 70k while you're in school
no so I actually can't work the first
semester it's a commitment we have to
make to enter the program at the end of
the next three semesters I can but I'm
not sure I'll be making
okay and that's something to think about
for sure if you guys have a giant dip in
income because how much is she making
working from home part-time
she's making around 25 right now out of
the 70.
yeah okay
and have you all figured out your budget
with the new city because Salt Lake is
that going to be a pretty expensive yeah
yeah it's a lot we we've kind of
estimated that right now we're only
spending about 30 of what we're earning
um it's pretty cheap down here uh we'll
probably be spending closer to
um 60 on that first semester that I'm
not able to work here's a question
Andrew could you find a program that is
either local or online that would check
off the same box
they have some online programs the
tuition's a lot higher and this program
is kind of something I've been wanting
to do for a while I'm sure there would
be more local programs but
um
maybe in like U of A or something like
that but I'm just wondering if there's
one that you could do online you could
start now and keep your income and so
you could keep your household income at
70 keep your living expenses low you
could do all of this without having to
move as Newlyweds
well also Andrew is part of this that
you want to move like a Salt Lake
somewhere where you want to go is that
part of this equation
yeah it is somewhere we want to go and
kind of get a new experience for the
next couple years before we start a
family
okay so it's yeah partial for fun it's
an adventure The Newlywed Adventure
well I would do my due diligence and
figure out what it's going to cost to
live out there what does life look like
if we go down to twenty five thousand
dollars how are we going to afford life
out there so that this is an exciting
move that's moving you forward instead
of go looking back with regret going oh
my gosh what have we done yeah and
George correct me if I'm wrong but if if
I'm in your shoes I'm just saving cash
right now like I'm not worried about
investing it right now I'm not worried
about putting it somewhere I'm just
saving it one to make sure that I can
graduate debt free you know there's a
lot of factors that can play into things
a lot of unexpensed expected expenses
can pop up can pop up so I do I would
just want to make sure I have plenty of
money for that and then also you know
that first semester in Salt Lake it may
be a lot more expensive than you factor
in and you know you've got the 50 and
the 10 and the emergency funds in there
and the 25k intuition but with all those
factors you're still kind of close on it
so I would be saving as much as I can
right now just to make sure that we're
good
and that dream of home ownership will
come but I would want you out of the
master's program figure out where you
guys are going to live long term then we
can start looking at homes and the
bigger pile of money you have the sooner
you can make that happen
and the good news is that high yield
savings accounts they're making great
interest rates right now like at almost
at four percent
yeah we looked into that as well maybe
at some kind of CD or something for the
next few years because the money we make
in the next six months will pay for all
of schools so we'll have that just kind
of sitting around if we're going to be
renting and one thing to think about
Andrew with that Index Fund if you're
going to need that money soon I would
move that to a high yield savings
account even over a CD because that will
keep it liquid we call them certificates
of depression and right now that
high-yield savings account will get you
about as good of a rate if not higher
than any CD out there so good things to
think about do some more homework but uh
it sounds like you're making the right
moves and doing it without any debt we
love that let's move on to Joseph in
Cadillac Michigan Joseph welcome to the
show
thank you so much George and Christina
and thank you very much for taking my
call sure what's going on
I'm Soul uh just a little bit of a
backstory here um December 30th of last
year
um I paid my truck off and I am now
officially debt free
um something over 45 000 in about five
months way to go
thank you very much
um my question today is
um I live in a double wide on 20 acres
with a barn and within the next two to
three years I plan on moving and I only
owe
um 54 000 on my mortgage
and my question is did I treat this as
baby step two and just get this bait off
that way when I go to sell the house I
can just use the profit from the sale
towards the next home
or should I just continue on to baby
step three
so right now you have the debt paid off
but you have no emergency fund
correct I just started actually my last
paycheck I just started my emergency
fund okay cool I would continue on with
that emergency fund uh because in the
midst of you trying to pay off this
mortgage life's gonna happen and the
mortgage is very different from the
Consumer Debt and so I would just
continue on with the baby steps put that
in baby step six so begin investing
after you've got the emergency fund any
money left over beyond that let's start
attacking that mortgage and you can
still do all that what's your income
um it's ranges anywhere from like 85 to
120 depending on overtime love it I mean
if you paid off 45k in five months once
you've got the emergency fund you're
investing 15 you could probably still
pay off your mortgage within what eight
months
um yeah probably but thank you gazelle
intense with it I probably could I love
it I would just set that for a goal for
the year say hey how cool would it be if
by the end of 2023 I've got obviously no
Consumer Debt already I've got a fully
funded emergency fund I'm investing 15
toward my future and I don't have a
mortgage payment
perfect awesome that sounds great thanks
so much for answering my question then
absolutely Joseph I got excited just
thinking about it Christina right I'm
pumped for Joseph that's pretty exciting
and even if he went half that pace he
could still have this paid off that's
true by three he seems like a driven guy
he paid off 45k in five months I'm like
so he's not fooling around impressive I
love it that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Christina Ellis all the folks in
the booth Austin Ben James Zach and
Andrew and you America thanks for tuning
in we'll be back real soon
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by my colleague
Christina Ellis and we are taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five now
before we get into the calls here I want
to mention that if you enjoy this show I
want to remind you that it is free and
so here's the only thing I ask in return
You Don't Have To venmo Me here's all I
ask leave us a review subscribe to the
show and share it with a friend wherever
you're listening whatever platform
there's about a bajillion of them out
there we would so appreciate that we
want to spread this hope to so many more
people in 2023 and you are the way we do
that through word of mouth that's how
this happens
let's kick off the hour with Lori in
Kansas City Lori welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you so much
um so I'm calling because
because yay and I have a 1950s home that
is in desperate need of some remodeling
just to make it more livable
um my only concern about doing
remodeling that I want to do I don't
want to make my house the most expensive
house in the neighborhood because Dave
says not to you're not it's going to be
harder to get the money back
um there are homes in my neighborhood
that some have a basement and some do
not so I don't know how to like look at
the over overall View
of the values of homes in my area to get
a good price point as to like how much I
can invest in the remodeling of my home
are you planning on selling it or are
you going to live there for the
foreseeable future
yeah it's supposed to be my forever home
like that exactly okay well that changes
the way I look at it yeah and what kind
of remodels are we talking about
so the kitchen is original and it
doesn't have a dining kitchen so I'm
wanting to open up a wall for the
sunroom that has been finished in to
expand that and to add some storage in
there it'll make the house a lot more
comfortable
in anything else or is that the only
rental I mean dreaming big I'm gonna put
in like a faux deck in the back and a
hot tub but I mean it's already on party
at Lori's I love it so have you got an
estimated Freedom's great yeah yeah you
got the money to do it what is the home
worth
um I bought it at 130.
um the house just down the street sold
for 209 but it also has a basement so
that's also another thing I don't really
know if that factors in too much in the
value of the home so you think the home
might be worth around 200 now
uh that would be ambitious but yes okay
and how much are these uh Renovations
gonna cost just just the kids I don't
know exactly okay I haven't gotten that
far okay so still getting quotes
right yeah to make this less of an
emotional decision I would just do some
due diligence get in touch with some
contractors get in touch with a real
estate agent and say hey I'm gonna do
these remodels the remodels that I want
to do it's going to cost you know 25
Grand to do it the way I want to do it
will that increase my home value by
roughly that now if you're going to stay
there for a long time it just matters
less and less about the ROI it's okay if
you if Lori wants it and then Lori can
get it just know that you may not Roi on
that remodel and that's okay
okay so now if it's going to cost 150
Grand to do these Renovations I'm just
going to move at that point you know
yeah no way it's not like you live in a
million dollar neighborhood and so you
want to just take that into account when
you're doing these Renovations there's a
lot of things you can do that are kind
of a no demo renovation
um things like paint lighting front door
smart home upgrades Landscaping there's
a lot you can do without tearing down
walls and all that but I would get some
quotes and if it's reasonable and you're
cash flowing it it's okay if you don't
get the dime for dime Roi on that
investment
okay
um can I ask one more quick question
completely unrelated sure it's Lori's
show now so
I used to be a teacher and so I hear you
guys talking about teachers being like
the third most common millionaires is
that because they're also married
oh that's a good question I don't know
uh how that was taken into account in
the study regarding marriage what yeah I
don't know about married but I know that
Davis talked about how teachers are such
great planners they're great with
lessons lesson plans they're great at
working students through plans so when
they see a plan they tend to follow it
you know they follow the baby steps they
do it without question they're diligent
they stick with it they're able to stick
with it for 10 to 15 years so I know
that that's a huge factor in it and uh
from from what I gather there's a lot of
great retirement benefits for teachers
out there and so that also they that's
they know about that and so when they
get into the field there you hopefully
you know they're not trying to keep up
with the Joneses driving luxury cars
into the school and so they've just got
good heads on their shoulders where they
go I'm going to live on less than I make
you know I'm trying to just stay alive
here with all these kids I'm not trying
to impress anyone and I think that
causes you to make different decisions
financially Lori I'm questioning why I'm
curious why do you ask that question do
you have a special Insight yeah are you
married yeah I was a teacher for six
years and I struggled oh my gosh it was
really really hard of course this was
pretty Dave Ramsey but the only thing
that really did save me is they mandated
that I contribute 11 into the retirement
fund and so I'm looking back
looking back I'm so thankful because
that that compound interest is working
in my favor yeah if mom makes you eat
the vegetables you're eating vegetables
and you're going to be healthier because
of it and so that's part of the deal uh
are you married
uh no are you on the path to becoming a
baby steps millionaire
oh for sure yeah I love it that's
awesome well Laura you're doing great
I'm excited for the home renovations the
hot tub I mean that's the new American
Dream It's the hot tub right that's the
life that's like one of my go-to's when
we're looking on Airbnb or VRBO it's
like does it have a hot tub oh and
Christina you you are in the the home
buying process are you thinking about
these kinds of things when it comes to
Renovations and Dave always says we can
look past paint colors and ugly carpet
so when you're looking for a home you
don't want to make the decision just
based on what the photos look like
necessarily oh gosh there's so many
factors to it and I mean I've had
definitely had moments in looking at
houses the last few weeks where it's
like you see so many investors in the
market right now who are flipping
properties and it's like I don't want to
spend an extra hundred thousand dollars
because they picked out the carpet and
they picked out the paint it's like give
me you know the lower price and let me
fix it up I don't want to spend that
extra money because we're going to DIY a
bunch of that oh wow right well slate is
very rock and roll dude this guy can do
it all we're super Google like we want
to save the money we don't want to pray
pay premium for all those upgrades
that's true see I wanted to get in a
place in life where we could just hire
the handyman for 50 bucks an hour and we
just ate ice cream watching him put up
the floating wood shelf and I gotta tell
you that was luxurious that's that baby
step seven life George there's something
about watching someone else do hard work
while you don't that feels good oh you
know you're just like it's not me that'd
be awesome you mean you're not a
handyman uh you know I can hang up I
hang up pictures and I'm on the tech
side so like I will set up the entire
smart home and all the gadgets and
gizmos and the Wi-Fi but I don't want to
be out there you know doing drywall it's
just not for me yeah my parents didn't
immigrate to this country so I could do
drywall you know I want to support a
local handyman to do all that there you
go so there it is more of your calls
coming up on the Ramsay show give us a
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five we will talk
about your life and your money and help
you take that right next step in your
financial future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell Ramsay personality uh co-host
of this show of course but also smart
money happy hour with our friend Rachel
Cruz I'm joined this hour by Christina
Ellis taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five now
Christina you are doing this hashtag no
spend challenge in January and you've
taken a lot of people along for the ride
over on your Instagram and I need the
update have you been successful we are
doing it and we are succeeding so far so
for people that don't know what the no
spend challenge is how do you explain it
because it's not you obviously have to
pay the bills we're not saying don't pay
your mortgage yes you still pay the four
walls food utility shelter
Transportation but you try to cut out
all discretionary spending so you know
you pay your needs but you don't do any
once discretionary feels squishy oh my
gosh so it's it's everything that's you
know is it bad that I want to say it's
everything that's fun
so it's all the things that you don't
technically need anything you're excited
to spend money on is probably
discretionary right no eating out no
shopping and for us we're also trying to
cut back on our grocery budget so we've
given them ourselves a hundred dollars a
week to spend in today's economy I know
wow I know so it's really challenging us
it's we literally you sit down before
you do this you look at your budget and
you go through every line item and say
you know is this a need is this
essential to living my life and if it's
not we cut it out we cut our
miscellaneous budget we cut out shopping
we cut out makeup we cut out all the
things I mean granted if I start looking
kind of awkward on the show it's because
I ran out of something and that's all I
got for the month y'all a lot of people
go well Christina the drive-through on
my way to work is essential I need it
for my survival to get through the day
is it is it really oh Christina just
called you out oh man y'all and I I only
call you out because I'm feeling the
pain like I am feeling the pain right
now what's been the biggest Temptation
for you guys I mean our grocery budget
was getting pretty out of control it was
a bit ridiculous and I think it's easy
you know we're on baby steps four
through six it's easy for your budget to
start getting kind of fluffy and Squishy
and so you know you're saving we're
saving money to pay off the house it's
easy to go you know what inflation we're
just gonna move a little money into our
grocery budget to increase it just a
little bit and all of a sudden we look
we look at our budget and we're like
this is nuts we should not be spending
this much money on groceries and so
we've really had to sit down and
strategize and think through you know
how can we still eat healthy but eat for
a hundred dollars or less a week and so
far we've only spent 45 dollars the
first week and 38 dollars the second
week are your kids getting skinny what
are we feeding them like ice cubes and a
gust of wind how are you doing this now
part of the challenge is also using
Pantry items so we've been bad about
food waste you know we we were busy we
have a one and a four year old we're
running around some days we're just
trying to survive so it's easy to just
be like this is what we're eating this
week and we're gonna buy what we need
and then we go through pantry and we
throw away a trash bag full of stuff
that we could have eaten but it went bad
so it's like really challenging us to
Think Through you know how can we use
what we already have how can we be super
strategic and just use what we have go
to the grocery store with a meal plan
with a list shop sales and just really
cut it back and I'm learning so much
through this because it's like wait we
can eat on about 400 a month like we as
a family of four as a family of four
it's been really eye-opening it's
challenging but forcing yourself to not
have another option and to really cut
back and break some of the bad habits
has been huge another big thing is
eating out we hit the spot Friday night
where we're rushing around we're trying
to go to the gym you know I worked all
day and we just have this moment we're
like yeah we'll just grab food on the
way home and it's like no we won't and
the thing is we had leftovers in the
fridge we were able to cook something up
in 10 minutes we saved 30 bucks that on
a different month we would have just
been like huh yeah we'll just buy food
on the way out it's easy I found out
Christina people there are people out
there who are just anti-lectovers they
just refuse to eat it whoa we are not
those people but
here's the thing if you're broke you
don't have a choice right like you're
eating those leftovers and in the camel
household Mama camel we had leftovers
that was this line when we went past any
drive through and I tried to you know I
made my case to go to the drive-through
what do they say we've got food at home
and exactly that's the line that shut
everything down we have food at home
well and the thing is with some of these
meals so I put out a meal plan on my
Instagram kind of walking through what
we're doing
um what our family's eating this month
and there are several meals that were
like seven bucks so it's like even if
you don't like leftovers if you're
willing to be strategic if you're
willing to take 10 minutes to cook you
know you can do that and here's the
thing I don't like cooking like I'm not
going to be the person that puts out
like recipes or things like that because
it's it's just not my thing I want
things that are super easy and super
simple so I think a lot of people may
resist and go well I have to eat on
Tuesday night because we've got soccer
we've got band and we got to do all
these things but there are plenty of
recipes that you can cook quick you can
do it in the morning you can do it over
lunch and get it done and out of the way
so you can save money but no excuses no
excuses it's just about prioritizing and
you see the margin and that keeps you
going because now you want to keep this
up it's super exciting and I know a lot
of you are doing it with me and it's
super exciting seeing your messages
seeing how you're carving out space in
your budget how you started the year
thinking you know I'm not going to be
able to pay off my student loan I'm not
going to be be able to save my emergency
fund but when you get that momentum and
you look through your budget and you go
wow I'm spending way more than I thought
I was on silly things on stupid things
that don't really matter then you can
cut it back and you can see that
progress but I will say we are reaching
that time of the month both with the no
spend Challenge and just with goals in
general where people start giving up
this is I was reading a bunch of
articles about like the cliche times
people give up on their New Year's
resolutions or they give up on
challenges for 30 day challenges days 10
and 11 tend to be when people give up
and then for Resolutions there's
actually a fitness app that was kind of
making fun of people and they called
January 17th to give up day wow it's
like the cliche Day called out right and
then the 19th is what another study
found so it's like if you have goals
right now if you have resolutions if
you're doing the challenge with me and
you're starting to feel discouraged this
is the time to push through this is the
time to buckle down look at your plan
again if you didn't have a plan create a
plan if you don't have a calendar where
you're checking off your progress do
that if you don't have a goal planner
that George put out with the team you
know have that but get clear on those
goals and really press in this is the
tools and accountability you need yeah
this is the time where it's hard if it's
hard I'm right there with you we can do
this well keep it up inspiring us all to
Greatness Eric is up next in Mesa
Arizona Eric welcome to the show
thank you what's going on
well uh I'm trying to determine if my
wife and I need life insurance at the
life stage that we're in okay
okay well uh I'm 57 she's 52.
um our house is paid for we've got
uh I would argue a substantial amount of
money in various uh retirement Vehicles
how much is your NASA combined uh
well for retirement we're somewhere in
the neighbor well last year it was more
now it's down to probably 1.5 million
okay
and kids are they in the picture
uh they're grown we just spoil the
grandkids now oh I love it and do you
have life insurance currently
we did up until two months ago uh we had
term life insurance we were carrying uh
uh basically 500k on each of us
um the term expired now our age and
everything has changed so the rates are
now astronomical
so I decided to let it lapse we both are
employed still so we can get some life
insurance through work at a reasonable
price
but obviously if we decide to retire
quit then that goes away so I'm just
trying to determine whether we actually
need it at this point in the game you
don't my friend you are what we call
self-insured
because no one is relying on your income
except your spouse correct
uh right and so if something happened to
Eric she's gonna be okay because she's
got 1.5 million dollars
to live off of and so if you just invest
a portion of that pull off a portion of
that she's going to be okay and so
that's the whole goal of this plan and
you are a great picture of that a poster
child if you will for being self-insured
and following these steps
okay do you feel the peace I mean you
got a million and a half in the bank
that 500 000 policy was a third of that
well based on the current Administration
and their spending habits I still don't
feel that comfortable well I I can't
give you confidence in the White House
Eric I don't think anyone can but the
good news is you've taken control of
your house and uh you've done so well
investing for the future you've got no
debt very little risk in your life and
so you can sleep easy knowing yourself
insured very proud of you guys way to go
following these steps the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsay show
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back America this is your show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we want to help you take the right
next step with your money if you're not
where you want to be financially you
need a second opinion that's not your
broke brother-in-law we are here for you
Peter joins us up next in
Charlottesville Virginia Peter welcome
to the show
hey Jordan Christina an honor to speak
with you guys thank you so much for all
that you do oh we appreciate that how
can we help today
so my wife and I my wife is 25 I'm 24.
we have an eight-month-old baby and we
have been married for almost two years
now coming up on our two-year
anniversary
and we've been saving for a home those
whole two years
and uh I spoke with the smart Master Pro
about whether or not we should start
investing for retirement or say for a
home about a year and a half ago and
they suggested we stay for the home
problem is we've only been able to save
about eight thousand for a home in those
two years and it's just feeling like no
matter what we do no matter how simply
we try to live and save for a home down
payment
um we're just not able to make any
traction wondering if you have any
advice for us
well good on your smartvest or Pro for
telling you to save up for the down
payment instead of invest because most
financial planners out there are going
to say hey you should absolutely invest
while we waste your time and money
saving up for that down payment and so
that's awesome and I do think two years
would be the max I would go all right we
got to start investing because we also
need to take care of our future and you
can continue saving up for that down
payment obviously it's going to slow you
down a bit to reduce it by 15 right
yeah significantly but I don't think the
15 is the issue here it sounds like we
have an income problem
what's the household income
so my wife is at home with the baby but
I make 46 000 a year what do you do and
that
I am a uh
a leader on a landscaping crew cool so
my income is going up and I'm very
satisfied in my job I love what I do and
I want to stick here I've thought a lot
about switching jobs to make more money
um but I'm working a lot of overtime as
much as I can but the biggest problem is
that my wife and I are also in Ministry
at our church
so that takes evenings and stuff like
that where I would be able to make more
income are you on staff at the church or
is it volunteer based
it's volunteer
okay and with the overtime is it
primarily with your full-time job
it's with my full all of my full-time
job so what is your what's your base
salary before you do the overtime
uh 22 an hour
okay what about you said that you you
love the full-time job but how about
doing like a side hustle where you're
you're building the clientele and you're
making a little bit more money outside
that full-time job
I've done some of that I'm I'm decently
handy and I've done several handyman
jobs here and there biggest thing is
finding time out of our schedule to do
it
I would honestly I would back off of the
volunteer Ministry for a season in order
to step up the side work and get that
income up and then we can step back into
it once we're closer to the goal
would you be able to do that okay
possibly yeah okay so here's what I'm
saying I mean the handyman work I've
hired lots of handyman we just talked
about this and you can easily make 50
bucks to 75 bucks to 90 bucks an hour
doing handyman work now obviously your
area it depends on your neighborhood
your area but if you just become the
neighborhood handyman and you get in the
in the Facebook group and you say hey
I'm here here's my hourly rate call me
it's amazing how much work you'll get
just doing that and you could double
your income I mean you're making 22 you
could easily charge 50 an hour and
there's a huge need for it now I feel
like people right now are like clamoring
after handyman that we've had neighbors
and people posting on Facebook where
they're like I can't find anybody who
does quality work who has integrity and
will show will show up so it's like if
you are that guy if you get that
reputation you could develop a really
great business
are you guys doing a monthly budget
together
we are yes we went through financial
peace several months ago and um we had
been kind of on a ish budget up to that
point and we've been we've been cutting
everything down as much as we can and
Christina we're actually
hoping to in February either no spend
money yes yes
let's go that will be eye-opening for
sure because the question is you saved
8K in two years and so dividing that out
the math just hurts my brain going wait
how is that possible that you were only
saving you know 300 bucks a month where
is the rest of this you mean you have a
decent income here so where is the rest
of it going when once you guys started
doing the budget where are the money
leaks happening
so it was happening a lot on impulse
spending
and just living comfortably
is where it was
and like three months ago we really
started pulling our pants up and saying
we really need to to get somewhere with
this we were almost two years into this
and only saved up by 8 000. okay well it
sounds like things have changed and
that's great so I'm gonna begin
investing 15 of my income beyond that
I'm gonna go what is the goal we have
for this down payment we have eight I
need to get to 25 30. okay that means
we've got a 22 000 Gap that I need to
fill in the next two years that's my
goal can I make eleven thousand dollars
extra a year to put into the savings
account and the answer is yes because
this side job alone 50 bucks an hour
doing handyman work and you work 10
hours a week that's five hundred dollars
extra
every single week well and I love that
you're doing both because one of the
biggest things that's like you need to
stop the bleeding so many people
immediately go to you know getting
another job and adding more income but
it's like if you don't stop the bleeding
if you don't get control of your
spending then you're just gonna keep
upping that budget it's going to be you
know a lack of discipline and it's just
gonna bleed out so the fact that you're
doing the no spin challenge that you're
going to face the bad habits that you're
going to tighten in and you're going to
increase your income that's where you're
really going to see some progress in
momentum so I would sit down with your
wife Peter and say Hey I want to make
sure that I set our family up for
Success financially I want us to be
homeowners and I don't want it to be 10
years from now here's my plan I'm going
to scale back on the volunteering at the
church I'm going to up my side income
I'm going to start this kind of side
handyman business here's how much I'm
going to charge here's how much I'm
going to work and that will create this
much extra income for us
you think she'd be cool with that sure
oh yeah she's definitely on board we're
in this together I love it well I think
that's going to change the game for you
guys and once you do it and you see the
progress in a month and two months I
mean if we're talking the numbers I just
threw out there that handyman gig alone
at 10 hours that's two thousand dollars
extra a month that's 24 000 a year do
you start to see how this stuff
compounds and changes the numbers
yeah wow I didn't really do the math on
that that's inspiring stuff when you do
the math and it's in it's to your
benefit and so I mean I'm cheering you
on this is an awesome thing and again
the folks in the trades if you are handy
and you're good with your hands you can
make so much money and I know that
because I've given a lot of that money
to them and I'm happy to because I don't
want to deal with it and people like
Peter they love it they live for it and
uh don't discount the value that you
have
especially if you're in those spaces and
don't discount how much a side hustle
can impact your life and a lot of people
say well I already work too hard but man
it becomes addictive once you go oh I
can make 300 bucks on an evening just
doing that changing light bulbs oh my
goodness sign me up right well and with
the trades you're always going to have a
job like there's always going to be
somebody like George who wants to hire
you thank you Christina I'm happily
supporting the trades because I mean you
talk about electricians and plumbers and
HVAC these are things that people are
willing to pay others for and pay you
will never be automated by the robots
I'm sorry so that is very encouraging
for those in the trades and people in
Peter's situation where you go we're
doing the baby steps we're not making
the traction we should be we're
discouraged start to look at those
numbers and start to do the math and say
if we cut these expenses that's 50 bucks
a month or it doesn't sound like much
but that's 600 bucks a year and now what
else could we do to bring in more income
well if we bring 500 extra bucks a month
month that's six thousand a year and
then you really start to feel the
progress and you're motivated to do it
because you see the results yeah it's
fun to just have a dream session like a
lot of people don't think numbers can be
exciting but when you see them add up
and you see the impact over time that'll
get you pretty stoked I love it and if
you want to know this plane you're like
what are they talking about 3B the two
and the we've got a really great
resource for you on ramseysolutions.com
click on the get started button and
after taking a few questions we're going
to throw a bunch of tools and resources
at you and teach you this Ramsay plan
that has helped so many people get out
of debt build wealth and feel like they
are in control of their money for the
very first time and we are cheering you
on in that process in 2023. more of the
Ramsay show coming up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show about
this time of year we get flooded with
calls on the show because everyone is
looking for a fresh start with their
money especially after a tough couple of
years so if that's you you can't wish
for things to change and expect it to
happen you've got to do some things
differently when it comes to your money
you've got to have a plan and we teach
you that plan in Financial Peace
University this is the course that will
help you rethink how you manage your
money and you'll learn step by step how
to pay off debt and how to build wealth
and here's the crazy part nearly 10
million people have now gone through FPU
they've followed this plan and they've
changed their lives I'm one of those
people this stuff works don't try to
reinvent it I've tried George's plan
back in the day that didn't get me very
far but Dave Ramsey's original plan the
OG 30 years now 10 million people it's
hard to beat that and when you
intentionally follow this plan with
Focus intensity this year will be
different you'll have more peace in your
finances and your life so go start
Financial Peace University right now at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Kalina joins us up next in Chattanooga
Kalina welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
um so my husband and I just started the
baby step
um we're in baby step two and we have
two vehicles one has a loan we know
we're selling that one but the second
one is paid for and I'm just trying to
determine if we need to sell it or not
okay what's your household income
um we bring home about seven to eight
thousand a month okay
and what are these cars worth
um well the one that's got the loan it
has 27 000 on it it's worth about 34.
um and so we're gonna we've already
listed that one but the um the one
that's paid off okay thousand and why
why are you wanting to sell the paid off
car
thinking that I could get something
cheaper and take the
um you know equity and pay off something
so what other debt do you have
well we have about 150 000 in Consumer
Debt
okay list some of that out for me is
that on top of the car loan or is that
total no well that's what that's what
that's what that's total um we've got
some personal loans
um credit cards and student loans
yep now making you're taking home 96 000
a year about 80 90 or is that gross yeah
yeah we're we're taking on that no
grosses were closer to 120 130 probably
okay so the question is how quickly will
you pay off that 150 going gazelle
intents have you guys done the math on
that or used our debt snowball
calculator
um we have um we signed up for the fbu
and so I've put our debt in there right
now it's saying like September of
2026. well um
right
um and I don't like that so like I mean
it was just saying that and I think I
just put like minimum payments for
something in there okay
um you know and that has the truck in it
too that we're selling so once that
comes off I know it'll drop but and are
you both working full-time right now
yes I'm a teacher my husband does HVAC
so can either of you work overtime to
increase your income um well I'm gonna
take on whatever homebounds I get which
will help and then do some after school
tutoring
um we have two little ones as well so
it's kind of a kind of hard yeah
um what are their ages
uh three and five so okay so they're
still not in school you're still in the
in the thick of it do you like this paid
off car
um I love my car it I mean my car is a
paid offline it's a forerunner I love it
like but you know it's got 140 000 miles
on it so kind of one of those things
like am I gonna find something
you know equally reliable that I don't
have to worry about
um if I'm in your shoes I'm not selling
it it's paid for you're not going to
free up a payment here and if you guys
sell this truck my goal would for would
be for you guys to be completely debt
free in two years
that's mine too and so reverse engineer
that and go okay after the the truck is
sold that takes our debt from 150 down
to you know 125. all right how quickly
can we pay off 125 making 120. all right
well let's see if we can throw 60 000 a
year at this debt then right
right and so now we start doing the math
and going that's 5 000 a month how do we
find five thousand dollars worth of
margin in our budget every single month
what would we have to do we'd have to
cut expenses for sure
right you probably have to sell more
stuff
yeah we started the budget on the app
you guys have on every dollar trial yep
so I started that this month I'm still
kind of figuring it out you know there's
a lot of things in there yeah it takes
about 90 days to dial in that budget but
the key is to do it every month track
your spending figure out where we went
wrong oh we thought we were going to
spend 500 bucks on food turns out we
spent six and really I think we could
get it down to four because we were a
little bit lackadaisical with it right
so it takes a little bit to get that
piece dialed in but I think with your
income and working overtime and selling
this truck you're willing to do the
right things so now it just becomes a
game of math and it kind of gets
addictive regard we're able to do 4 000
this month on the debt how can we get to
4 500 and then to five thousand and
fifty five hundred
well and I I love that you're calling to
even ask that question you know we're
saying you know don't sell it but the
fact that you're calling and saying I am
ready to get so gazelle intense that I
will sell things I will do whatever it
takes to get rid of this debt keep that
yeah that's amazing
she is done over the debt yes my husband
is on my husband's on board but he's not
quite as intense as I am right now
though oh well he better be watching
those Financial Peace University videos
with you creating the budget with you
that's a huge part of this and he needs
to see the math too and go here's how
much we're throwing away to lenders and
interests here's so much we could be
investing in Building Wealth and here's
how much more quickly we could pay this
off if we get intense so thank you so
much for the call love that you guys are
going through Financial Peace University
and I'd love to hear that I've had it
moment like that is when people succeed
whenever they've had that moment where
they're like I'm so sick of it I am
willing to have a yard sale I'm willing
to sell the truck I'm willing to do what
it takes to get rid of that debt that's
an amazing feeling and you could hear it
in her voice uh oh I'm done I'm done we
were living la vida loca and we went 150
000 into Consumer Debt and we looked
good and we felt terrible it's amazing
how that works the better you look well
without actually owning anything and the
more payments you have in your life the
worse you actually feel behind the
scenes um yeah and I think that there's
like she said she's in the first month
of budgeting so she's had the I've had
it moment and now it's where the rubber
meets the road and she's got to start
budgeting and that part can be really
hard there's a lot of people who you
know they get on every dollar they try
it for the first month and they're like
ah I'm not good at budgeting but I just
want you to know that a lot of people
feel that way I would venture to say
most people feel that way like a lot of
people are just not natural budgeters
but you have have to stay with it it's
like working out you know the first time
if I went out and tried to run a mile
right now I would struggle but you'd
still beat me so that's good news that
may not be the best example
but keep at it because over time you
will get better it's like anything you
try to do for the first time like don't
expect to be amazing the first month but
over time you will get better it will
feel easier and you'll get the hang of
it I love it and a huge part of
budgeting it's you're looking in the
financial mirror and that's scary and
sometimes it makes you want to throw up
but that first step of just showing up
and being willing to actually look at
your money and go where did it go I'm
working so hard what is all this for we
make sixty thousand dollars a year where
did it go and you start to look at your
bank transactions and those little
things start to add up and you forgot
about that bill and you didn't pay
attention to that and then you got
emotional you were tired there was some
retail therapy I wanted to eat out I
want I want I want and when we act like
children like that we end up real broke
and miserable right but doing that
budget for the first time and going oh
that's not pretty I gotta change the way
I spend on food you want to start
cooking at home like Christina spending
45 bucks a week on groceries for a
family of four turn turns out you can do
it it's a choice it's a great reminder
it's a great reminder and it's hard I
mean there are emotional parts of those
first few months where you're like man
this is like kind of embarrassing that I
like spent this much on groceries it's
kind of embarrassing that I spent this
much on shopping but it's like you know
we all make dumb decisions with money at
some point own it and then change it
yeah we can't walk around with that
baggage and shame we just gotta move
forward and go all right the good news
is I can change God gave me that ability
and it's wonderful so thank you so much
Christina great hour of the Ramsay show
it's another one in the books we'll be
back real soon
foreign
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Ramsey
personality Join This Hour by my
colleague Christina Ellis and we are
here for you America taking your calls
about life triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's get to the
phones Elizabeth is in Toronto Canada
all right Elizabeth how you doing
hi George hi Christina I enjoy watching
the both of you great um Dynamics on
YouTube oh thank you congratulations
what an honor to talk with you how can
we help today thank you so I'm calling
because I have my question is around
should I pay them should pay off my
HELOC or should I pay off down my
mortgage and the reason being is that my
mortgage is a hundred and nineteen
thousand
um paying seven percent I did not it
came to you in uh December 1st of last
year and I decided not to renew it until
I figured out what I'm gonna do with it
so right now I'm paying two thousand and
twenty three dollars that includes a
mortgage insurance
as well as the HELOC it's seven to seven
thousand five hundred and odd dollars I
have the money to pay off the HELOC
except that if I paid up it's locked in
uh it's a variable rate locked in over
five years I've already done a year and
a half into that and I'm thinking if I
had to break it it's gonna cost me to
pay it off it's going to cost me about
1500 a little over fifteen hundred
dollars
so I'm thinking if I put I know you guys
say consumers that get rid of it
particularly the HELOC but I'm thinking
if I and I'm paying right now
772 dollars per month on the HELOC
um I doubled the payment for to
um
deal with the inflation
um but with the um
the sorry the um the mortgage
um
what I'm thinking I'm paying 2023
dollars and if I were to pay down 77 000
on that 119 obviously would be less and
I'll free up some more money faster to
pay down the mortgage this year and then
I could focus on throwing all of the
extra money as well as the money once I
pay off the mortgage towards the HELOC
so how much money do you have advice on
that
how much money do you have saved up
right now
I have a 77 000 and it could be a little
more okay so the the only downside to
paying off this HELOC is this fifteen
hundred dollar penalty stupid tax
yes I'm taking that deal
really yeah
okay because that frees up all right it
you're freeing up almost 800 bucks a
month number one and that would come
before the mortgage as far as payoff
anyways what's your income
um I make a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars awesome great income and does
that 77 000 does that include your
emergency fund or is there a separate
fund for that no it's separate okay
great so you already have the emergency
fund
yes okay yeah
do you have any other debt other than
this HELOC and the mortgage no
okay so think about this plan you pay
off the HELOC today you still have your
emergency fund intact now we can attack
that 119 000 mortgage with your hundred
fifteen thousand dollar income how
quickly do you think you could pay off
the mortgage within a few years
well I was I gave myself to pay be debt
free in two years I love this plan and
so getting rid of this HELOC is going to
help you get there
and that's something you can do pretty
much today right you have 77 000 yes
Save that's that's amazing that's gonna
feel so super excited about you being
free from this thing today does that
include the 1500 stupid tax
um no that's extra okay so do you need
to have that before you can pay this off
in full
okay great and you've got extra money in
the bank outside of the 77 you mentioned
right
um
just not a whole lot but something not a
whole lot okay how much is in your
emergency fund
my emergency fund I only have a thousand
oh okay so it's not the fully funded
emergency fund
no okay you mean for six months yes so
that that would be your next goal we're
not going to be ready to start attacking
the mortgage we need to pay off this
HELOC then we're going to be fully
funding that emergency fund with three
to six months of expenses then we can
begin investing 15 are you doing any
investing right now
no I'm not doing any investing and I'm
getting close to retirement I'm a single
woman close to retirement
well no better time than like the
president how old are you
I'm 64. okay how long do you want to
work for before retirement well I'm
thinking another two years but I I'm
gonna work until I there's nothing wrong
with me I'm gonna work until
um I pay off my debt and then I'll
retire well then that puts a little bit
of fire under me to get rid of this debt
as quickly as possible especially with
that great income
now when you retire what money will you
live off of
see that's the thing right I had so many
shoes so um I I have no savings I have a
home that's worth 1.5 million that's a
good problem to have other than that I
have a pension that I will be getting
and I think it's like a forty thousand
dollars pension and in addition to that
I'll be getting
um some government like pension
um the government pension plan and only
security is it kind of like Canada's
version of Social Security
I guess so yes okay
well let's start doing some math going
how much can I live off of you know if I
need to go from 115 down to 50 with no
mortgage payment can I do that so start
crunching these numbers and get a real
solid game plan for what the next five
years of your life looks like
and I'm just curious what the hell has
long term a 1.5 million dollar house do
you plan to stay there through
retirement or is it a possibility to
sell that
well I you know two years ago just
before covet I was planning to sell it
but then now with everything I am
thinking I'm still playing with it so in
the next two three years two years or so
I'm not going to sell it but at some
point I have to make a decision what I
want to do with it well the next two to
three years you're going to pay it off
and then your options are wide open
exactly so this is a this is a good
safety my income when I retire would be
about five thousand dollars net yeah
well if you wanted to sell that and
downsize and use a chunk of that to
invest to create some extra retirement
income that's an option as well so be
thinking about all that and uh we're
wishing you the best and it sounds like
you're you're so close to complete debt
Freedom by retirement that is an awesome
goal to have what a pleasure it was to
talk to you thanks so much for the call
more of your calls coming up America
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well Christina we talk a lot on the show
about Building Wealth and there's a lot
of ways to do it and most of them are
not great and this was an interesting
article from money wise that I wanted to
get your take on here's the headline
investing in art is a great hedge
against inflation and you don't need
Millions to buy in
hmm
huh head tilt so it goes on to say the
current state of the economy has dealt
with some heavy hits for the everyday
investor it goes on to talk about
inflation and then it goes on to talk
about these alternative Investments so
these are assets that are not stocks
they can help hedge against inflation
protect your wealth from downside risk
and potentially enhance portfolio
returns ooh sounds so fast yeah that's a
very fun word and there's a startup
called Masterworks that is trying to
kind of disrupt this industry
uh which art is a 1.7 trillion dollar
asset class according to Deloitte which
is pretty it's pretty wild and they say
contemporary art has outperformed the S
P 500 by 131 for the past 26 years and
it has nearly zero correlation to stocks
according to City
it's an interesting stats I don't know I
mean it feels a little bit biased this
whole article feels like it was paid for
by Masterworks so I don't know how much
I can trust it but it's an interesting
concept this idea and I think what
Masterworks is doing is much like you
know you buying a stock a little share
of a company you can own like a share of
the Mona Lisa whoa so you get a little
tiny piece of the Mona Lisa and the
ideas art appreciates over time as it
gets older age is like a fine wine and
you're you end up making money from that
investment
well George I'm super curious how you
feel about this because I know how much
you love crypto and all the the crypto
love art fun new forms of investing yeah
I uh I'm not a fan I'm I'm just gonna
say it right now this feels uh super
risky even though they're saying has
very little risk I would much rather
invest into things that uh I understand
I would rather invest in my 401k in
mutual funds versus alternative
Investments what do you think is so
attractive about all these like
different unique kind of funky ways of
investing like why do you think
especially gen Z is so drawn to this I
think they don't see the value and
they're trying to like go to the Future
where the trends are and the technology
which is why crypto became so popular
because everyone's talking about the
blockchain and the world's going to
exist on a blockchain Christina so you
want to be where the blockchain is don't
miss out and that's why nfts are going
to be great oh wait nfts crashed 2-0
okay and so I think a lot of it is we
don't want to do the things our parents
did because we saw how they lived their
life and the 401K is is not exciting and
there's so many people coming at them
now to get their money to get them into
other Investments crypto
art with Masterworks there's all kinds
of options these days and there's so
much noise out there it can be hard to
choose the right investment opportunity
right one and a lot of them can seem
really attractive like I read this and
it's like oh wow it outperformed the S P
500 like that's interesting and and you
know it can be enticing but on the flip
side of that I see that and I go I don't
know art I don't know that I would pick
the right one I would probably pick the
one that's a dug like uh doesn't do well
so it's just it is hard to navigate some
of this right now because it's not like
they're saying hey invest in this thing
that's going to crash in five years like
when crypto is at its hottest it's like
it's only going to the moon like it's
going to be the next thing and it's hard
to discern you know what's real and
what's not absolutely we always say
around here invest in things with a
proven track record that you understand
yep and art I'm just not in that world
I'm not an art collector and uh what I
do like about this this and there's
other things about you know there's
there's all kinds of DIY investing apps
what I do like about all this is we have
democratized investing now anyone can do
it but here's the problem anyone can do
it which means any old person can start
to make some terrible decisions we just
took a call yesterday on the show a guy
got excited about the GameStop situation
at AMC and he did all these put options
trading and he lost a hundred thirty
thousand dollars and he's got a wife and
three kids oh and now he's at rock
bottom
oh but he saw other people do it and
make money and therefore I'm going to do
it and make money and it just doesn't
work like that and so I'd rather get
rich slow than attempt to get rich quick
and not that this feels that way I mean
if you're investing in art this is a
more of a long-term investment you're
holding this but I think unless you have
fun money and you love art I just I
wouldn't go near this that's my take I'm
with you I think there are some people
that could probably do it well people
who've really studied art for but but
for the great majority of people
probably not the right thing I don't
think this is one of those I'm gonna go
sign up for an account and just throw 10
grand in there for fun see what happens
oh my gosh if you could light that money
on fire on the kitchen table and not
miss it go for it good for you I'm not
at that point yet right I remember
reading some like Forum article at one
point about Bitcoin and there was
somebody who posted that they put all of
their Savings in Bitcoin because
everybody said it always goes up and now
it went to zero and even the Bitcoin
guys were like dude that was stupid
like oh man it just hurts my heart yikes
stay safe out there people all right
Todd joins us up next in Toledo Ohio
Todd welcome to the show
hi thank you guys for having me yeah if
I sound nervous at all this is my first
call with you guys hey we're freaking
out with you man we're we're gonna do
great we're in this together
thank you
well I am
a 20 year old kid and I
my mom is going to a foreclosure and it
supports me and my brother to take out a
loan and I'm wondering if there's
anything that I should do that I may
have not thought of oh Todd I'm so sorry
how did she end up in foreclosure
well during the pandemic uh we were
kind of in a rough spot and we
almost um we were forced to basically
get a loan for our house because we
qualified for it and
she ended up using the house as
collateral and she made a late payment
on the loan and she thought it'd be fine
you know just pay like the late fee or
whatever but they were like no there's
no late fee we're going to take your
house unless you can pay back this loan
and the loan was for basically two years
of house payment
and
uh so now we owe about
35k to 40K
on it who's we
uh it's me my brother and my mom so
you're already on this loan
yes I I had to take it out just because
like it's due uh to be paid off uh this
Friday
what's due to be paid off the the thirty
five thousand dollar loan
yes
okay or what
um
or you lose the house
yes basically
how much is the house worth
um I believe it's worth 260k
so you said during the pandemic
you had to take out the loan and you had
the opportunity to was that
to afford your house payments
or what kind of led to the to taking out
the loan
it was basically we
my mom wanted to defer her money it
sounded like a good deal to my mom I
personally wouldn't take out any loan
but she thought it was a good deal and
took out the loan and now we're just
kind of in this situation
so on Friday is the entire loan due or
do you you said they won't take a look
I don't know what kind of shady loan you
guys signed up for but this is a
nightmare Todd and you keep saying that
I we were forced
I've never heard of someone forcing you
to take out a loan
okay it wasn't like a loan shark kind of
thing it was through
um am I allowed to say the name sure
it was through lone care and then it was
some uh
agency that my mom's been using for ever
I I don't know
Todd well you were you're growing up
fast for 20 because this is an adult
decision you made to co-sign on this
debt
um I mean it sounds like you guys are
going to lose this house and we're gonna
need to find some place to rent I would
get in touch with a real estate attorney
to figure out what your rights are if
there's a way to save this thing uh but
you know on a quick call it's hard to
dig into all these details but man this
is just a lesson to never never co-sign
debt and to read the fine print I'm so
sorry you guys are going through this
Todd
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
just before the break we were talking to
Todd and Toledo and here's the situation
Mom missed a mortgage payment and him
and his brother co-signed a loan along
with her and uh the house is about to be
foreclosed on in a few days unless they
can pay this loan uh Todd we didn't want
to leave you hanging there so let's get
back to your situation here so as I
understand it you guys are taking a
personal loan out to cover this 35 40
000 Loan in order to save the house
correct okay and is that done
uh yes I took out a eight thousand
dollar loan and I also have five 5.05 6
000 and uh personal savings and my
brother had to take out 11k and he had
um
do you have some money and personal
savings yes and that covers the amount
that you guys needed
yes to cover this loan Care Loan and
your mom did she not qualify for
something to cover it why why why is it
you guys responsible for it
because that's exactly right uh she her
credit score is shot and she can't
really get any more money than uh much
from other than what's from our income
so what what's the actual mortgage
amount
what do you mean because you have the 35
40K loan is there another mortgage as
well on this house
uh yes I don't know how much left is on
it but we've had this house for at least
15 years or so so I'm assuming it's more
than half paid off okay and can your mom
afford the payment what is her income
uh she can't afford the payment it was
um
her income's about uh
60k a year okay and what is this
mortgage payment she needs to make every
month
I believe it's about
1500.
okay Enter you both are living there you
and your brother
yes
all right so your your question now
becomes hey we're gonna be able to keep
the house it's not going to get
foreclosed on we're going to pay this
loan off in time to avoid foreclosure
correct
which now leaves you guys with leaves
you personally with an 8 000 loan and no
savings and it leaves your brother with
an 11 000 loan and no savings
and then you still have oh I guess they
pay off that loan and that then just
leaves you with whatever mortgage was
originally on the house which is in your
mom's name
yes okay
so you're asking what is the plan going
forward for us to pay this off
all right we can do that now so what is
your income
I make about 33 000 a year okay
your brother makes the same
okay well your A1 is to get a thousand
dollar starter emergency fund both of
you separately thousand bucks in the
bank beyond that we're going to be
tackling these loans do you guys have
any other debt
uh no that's good news and I assume Mom
has nothing in the bank
uh not really other than low liquidity
stocks
okay so she is she able to sell those
off
not in time for this
because it needs to be all one big
payment by Friday but you guys already
have that money you're saying
okay so I would go ahead and make sure
this loan is cleared in time have you
contacted the lender to let them know
the situation
uh yes okay what's that what's that
discussion been like when you're on the
phone with them
um
basically I'll what they said is I could
probably be able to pay it off as within
the year because I me and my brother
made sure that we got along with no
um
prepayment penalty so we're just gonna
like as far as our plan goes we're just
gonna try and apply as much money as we
can this year to get them out of our air
you're talking about those personal
loans you guys took out for 8K and 11k
yes okay what about the 35 40 000 loan
that you're paying off to keep the house
it was
the loan basically was
Fed Up in a way to defer our house
payments to the loan so during the time
it's just we're making
we're just kind of paying off the house
in that sense
but when you call this this Lindner up
about the 35 to 40 000 what's the
conversation like have they threatened
you have they said you have to pay this
by Friday or report like tell me about
that conversation oh no yeah where in
the fine print was it hey if you miss a
payment it's due in full within a week
there was my mom who talked to them and
they they just kind of like
uh
they were just like oh yeah sorry we you
know you didn't make the payment so your
house is in foreclosure kind of thing
they really didn't like if any heads up
on that whole spectrum of you know that
side of the loan Okay this may be an
unpopular opinion but I'm kind of
frustrated with your mom right now like
you're 18 years old and she brought you
into the situation she is clearly not
handling her money well and she is
dragging her sons into this my heart
just hurts for you and I feel frustrated
and right now I'm not gonna trust your
mom's follow through on this financial
situation your name is on that loan how
do we know this isn't gonna happen again
um basically her plan is to either sell
the house what I want to do with the
house is I want to fix it up and then
make long-term money off of it by
renting it
um
and I I think that would be better but I
don't know what you guys would say on
that matter but here's the thing before
before we leave that I'm calling that
lender myself if I'm in your shoes like
you said your mom called them I want you
to pick up the phone and you to call
them because right now if you and your
brother take out those loans you're
essentially transferring the debt away
from your mother like your mom is on
that for 35k loan she's not gonna be on
this 8K and 11k right
that's putting that debt all in your
name she gets out of that 35 000
scot-free right and she gets to keep
living how she's been living like I'm
not letting her off the hook that easy
like I'm calling that is that is your
loan you call and you see if this is
really true that this whole Friday thing
is true if everything is due and you
have to take out a loan like I want the
details myself firsthand I would pick up
that phone and if it is true that
they're like you gotta pay it by Friday
then I'd say okay we're gonna negotiate
like right they don't want to really go
through foreclosure so then talk to them
and say I mean maybe they do because
they'd be getting a steal on that but I
would still talk to them and say I've
got this much money like will you take
20 right before you put all your savings
into it like see if you can negotiate
like take ownership of this situation it
is your life and your money and it's so
sad that at your age you're having to
deal with this that just frustrates me
to no end but I want to empower you to
take responsibility for the this and
actually follow through on all aspects
of this
okay thank you I if I'm in your shoes
you're saying Mom this is too much
you've put on us in a terrible financial
situation you put us in debt for your
home and we're selling this thing and
you're gonna go rent somewhere that you
can afford so that you don't get
foreclosed on again and it may be time
for for you and the brother to move out
and get it get your own place together
would that work agree yeah because this
is just a toxic situation and my word is
she keeps taking advantage of you guys
financially
yeah
and I think it's so important too like I
you know I'm all about honoring parents
and respecting and all of that and I
know you probably do want a relationship
going forward and if that's the case I'm
also going to say hey Mom we're gonna
sit down and take Financial Peace
University like what you're doing with
your life how you're managing your money
the fact that you're in such a mess like
that's not okay we need to sit down
together and clean up this mess like
it's not just going to be on me and my
brother to deal with this you got to sit
down with us like we're gonna get good
with money but so are you like I really
want you to do this with us
gotcha okay like I'm not I would say I'm
pretty good with money personally
because
um as far as a role model because you've
had to grow up fast
yeah I yeah it was like my mom was like
showing me everything not to do and I
was like okay I'm not gonna do this I'm
not gonna do that
thing well part of being good with money
Todd is not co-signing other people's
debt and you put yourself in a
precarious situation and uh you got a
great heart clearly you want to save
save the house and keep mom in there but
man this is a a big stupid tax we're
paying and we're gonna say never again
we're gonna change our family tree let's
get them Financial Peace University for
free hang on the line Austin will pick
up and get you that to get started
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show our scripture of
the day comes from Luke 12 15.
and he said to them take care and be on
your guard against all covetousness for
one's life does not consist in the
abundance of his possessions
Maya Angelou said we need much less than
we think we need
she was onto something there live on
less than you make it's okay I love it
well folks most of you are glad to be
rid of 2022 because it was tough to keep
gas in the card and food in the fridge
and for so many out there money is still
so tight and you might be wondering if
this year is going to be any different
well you don't have to live through
another year of stress and worry and
that's why we're putting on a free live
stream event called Building Wealth in
2023 happening this week January 12th
this Thursday 7 PM Central 8 PM eastern
time because we want to show you that
you can still make progress on your
goals you can build wealth you can have
peace with money even in this crazy
economy
at the event you're going to hear from
Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz myself Dr John
deloney and Ken Coleman we're going to
talk about how to set goals how to
create margin give you some peace about
what's happening out there in the
economy and the stock market so that you
can build wealth this year with
confidence we're gonna have some fun
there's some fun surprises and the good
news is even if the economy still feels
out of control by the end of the year
you don't have to register for this free
live stream tell your friends about it
ramseysolutions.com wealth you can tune
in from anywhere in the world that's
ramseysolutions.com wealth
Frank joins us up next in Charlotte
North Carolina Frank welcome to the show
thank you so much and thank you for
taking the time I'll try and keep it
brief I know a lot of people are trying
to talk to you guys I um my wife and I
got married uh in about 2021 and uh we
together made about 260 000 together you
know we my job had an annuity and a
pension hers had she had a 401k and a
she contributed to a Ross that wasn't
part of her job and then early last year
I had a really bad work accident and
I've been out of work since oh sorry
Frank you okay
I I'm still recovering I had four
surgeries this past 10 months
um I I don't you know I'm almost
positive I won't be going back into my
industry what kind of work are you doing
Construction
yeah that must have been a terrible
accident so sorry thank you I appreciate
that um yeah so we have I mean together
we have about 205 000 savings
um you know we were doing that
non-retirement so we weren't yeah so
it's not retirement okay
but my my everything was through my job
my annuity my pension you know my
pensions now
not really into the play as far as not
finishing up a career
um
so with where I'm at now I know we have
with where we're at now I just don't
know what I should do with my savings
based on where we're at how old are you
guys we're in our 30s and she's still
working
yes so she makes uh she makes about a
hundred and ten thousand
okay now or you know our bills are about
five thousand a month
with the only things we have at the
house and one of our cars we have a
mortgage on uh alone on okay what's left
on the car loan
uh it's about 25 and uh I think the car
is worth like 35 so I have about 25 left
on the car
and then she makes she brings in about 5
000 a month and our bills right now are
about 5 000 a month so our take-home pay
is 60 but she's making 110.
yeah right around there I mean those are
rough numbers but it's pretty pretty
close to the ballpark wow and do you all
own a home
yes
so ra1 is getting you guys a solid
financial position obviously you have
all the savings
um what's what's left on the mortgage
uh about 360. woof that's I assume most
of your expenses in that 5K is that
mortgage payment
yeah the mortgage I mean the one car is
500 a month which if we paid that out of
the savings you know that brings it down
to 4 500 a month putting an extra 500 in
a pocket but
you know I would I would pay off that
car today
if you want to keep it if you like the
car now if you hate the car sure you can
go sell it and get something cheaper
with cash
but as a part of your world it's not
that much and so you can keep it I would
just pay it off today if you want to do
that where did this uh 200 and savings
come from was that just I mean what was
the plan for that money why is it just
been sitting in savings
so we we were we were toying around with
the idea of buying a second home buying
a rental home buying a business we you
know we would go back and forth we both
worked a lot so there was not a lot of
time to discuss things and settle down
so I kind of just sat there for the last
you know 18 months or so
well I'm actually not even 18 months so
last year I got hurt and then all that's
all cut out the window so it was only
about you know nine or ten months before
I was talking about it before everything
changed well I would let this be a reset
moment for you guys where we say you
know what we don't want more risk in our
life we don't want more mortgages and
more payments we want less payments so
if something like this ever happened
again or one of us couldn't work we're
gonna be okay and so I would be focusing
on getting that getting rid of that
house payment paying off the mortgage
and being completely debt free investing
for the future and then later on down
the line we can talk about paying cash
for investment property
right so that's how I would walk this
out my also A1 is to get you doing uh
some kind of work that you can do if you
looked into another career
as of now it's all kind of up in the air
um I don't know what I'm going to be
capable of doing as far as work all I've
done is you know manual labor jobs
um this one the last one was paying well
and it was a great job are you the one
who's gonna spend like able to to drive
are you able to physically
do anything at the moment now okay well
maybe I just had another surgery
recently so I'm not having I'm not doing
anything right now well as you heal up
it may be prudent to look into some jobs
you could do even from home on a
computer something to uh to give you
some some purpose during the day once
you're healed up uh you you're obviously
your brain's working great and that's
it's a huge blessing
yeah I just I'm so stuck with with you
know like let's you know I pay off this
car you know we're sitting we have 180
000 left even if I keep 60 of it just to
pay the bills for the next year next two
years with her salary
you know there's 140 160 just sitting
there like is that something that should
be
doing something is that something that
should should I buy art you know
no Frank I want this money working for
you now's not the time to get fancy this
is not a pile of fun money we're gonna
go gamble away this is money I want you
guys to use to secure your future and so
that means we're paying down the
mortgage because once we have no
mortgage payment that really sets us up
to where even if you could never work
again she would be able to cover all the
bills with extra margin
okay yeah so we're putting away you know
some of that money for a fully funded
emergency fund three to six months of
expenses and is she still investing
toward retirement
yes okay great so keep doing that and
then from there do you all have kids
no kids okay okay so your next goal
would be to pay down that mortgage with
with her income right now and eventually
with your income
right and once we do that then we're at
baby step seven which is where we build
wealth and give that is when we can save
up more cash and get investment property
and Heck if you want to invest in some
art Frank down the line once the house
has paid off you can do that
you know it's never been been a thing of
mine I just heard you saying that a
minute ago good good good good well
Frank I'm so sorry about here but hear
about your situation man I mean I can't
imagine the emotional toll that's taken
on top of the financial one so we're
going to send you a copy of Dr John
deloney's book own your past change your
future and I think it will help you
figure out how to grieve this crazy
situation that you've went through and
move forward and heal
thank you I appreciate it absolutely
thanks for the call
man Christina that's a
we ended with a heavy call yesterday and
that's another heavy one we're yeah
someone experienced something traumatic
and their world just flips upside down
and the lesson I get from this on the
financial side is this plan works in
good times and in bad times and when you
don't owe anyone anything including a
house payment and you have a pile of
cash in the bank it changes the way you
make decisions you can move forward with
patience with Clarity with wisdom
instead of being scattered going how are
we going to cover next we got to pay the
bills we got to cover the mortgage we
got to pay all of our payments so it
just changes the way you make decisions
yeah that's huge because this situation
it was twofold there's the financial
side of things and then there's the
grief and the loss and the pain from you
know the accident so being able to focus
in on the financial conversation with
200 000 in the bank
it changes things when you got a pile of
money that's for sure well that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to my co-host Christina
Ellis all the guys in the booth Austin
Ben James Zack Andrew and you America
thank you for tuning in until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]